and then of course the e a press
conference ended with star wars
battlefront as promised Electra house
said it right from the beginning and
we've known we were going to get
gameplay ever since the reveal and lo
and behold the battle on ice planet hoth
I was actually traveling throughout the
whole thing it was so good everything
about it was exceptional I loved it so
much alright give me give me one thing
about it it was stood out in particular
I think it was the scope of the battle
so you could you could go into 80 80 s
or at that's how ever you want to
pronounce 8080 going to Wikipedia okay
you talked about earlier then what do
you call 80s alright that's the thing we
are not arguing Star Wars Canon here
does not that you go down that rabbit
hole yo not canon anyway yeah it since
you can just flying in ship's commanding
different vehicles having Jedi powers
seeing that Vader on the battlefield
just everything about it I I thought
they absolutely nailed than them I just
I can't wait to play this game it looks
incredible it's a beautiful-looking game
this is the impression I got when we got
to see the gameplay demo at Star Wars
Celebration was just the environmental
detail was rich like look at the the
stuff on the rocks see that kind of
detailing really pops in a way that it
doesn't feel distracting it just feels
enriching to the whole environment all
those footprints in the snow so they
said that dice have been working with a
process called photogrammetry yes which
is just basically you take a buttload of
photos of something like a cliff face
and then feed it into a program and it
spits out these really realistic looking
models it can just plunk straight into
the game and it's clear that it just
like it's helping the game look fun
title yeah it's such it's such a great
development tool and I guess more games
going to be using it now um but it's
just the whole game it just looks great
it looks so good and we saw some
vehicles in action here of course a TIE
fighter there's also x-wing flight these
of course are only in atmosphere they've
announced that there are no space
battles in Star Wars Battlefront also I
think I misspoke on the pre-show 40
players is the gives the Capitals not
for 32 that I mentioned so 20 per side
but had like
and the changing of perspectives right
between third person first person i hope
he ran out of ship view just incredible
and they do that in a ship they do that
in the 88th see they do that and you do
that on foot and you can do that at will
at any point in time depending on how
you prefer to play or what thus what you
think will give you a situational
advantage or if you just in this as in
this case want to take a look at your
sick green mohawk yeah yeah oh come and
sit like this was my favorite moment I
think just when the guy turns around and
yes it is buddy its just oh yeah we're
coming up to her now one of those nicely
scripted moments but yeah so you the
shield moment was really cool to sound
effects yep and that's you know part of
this sort of before I after class
customization now I oh you're right
having a neck problem oh look sighs so
fan service and I just love it look at
that pout they've got going oh yeah
that's that's full-on turtleneck
Skywalker's writing I like that battle
friend is letting you I know a lot of
people are like oh like it breaks the
immersion if you've drove three there in
the battlefield you know what I like
playing with cannon where else could you
do this running up to pursue this is
such a great moment absolutely yes give
you with excitement playing as those
here a hero characters definitely
something in battle fronts history
that's been wonderful they're bringing
it back in a big way I and battle fronts
coming out this fall yeah as excited
place your Wars one week after fallout
in Tomb Raider it's gonna be a busy yeah
uh embarrassment of riches hopefully as
all these games turn out to be as
exciting as we're hoping they will be
thank you folks so much for joining us
for our EA post conference pre and
post-show coming up next is the Ubisoft
press conference in just about 20
minutes we're going to take a break and
we're going to be back to stream that
press conference to you live and we back
with a post-show analysis following to
talk about all the highlights they're
all the stuff they hit all the new IP
they hopefully unveil and more
excitement here from e3 2015